[Music]
give time asbestos it right there y'all
ah welcome back to River with Griffin
it's always uplifting with the host jab
be lifted
yo I'm bad dude sometimes Rubidoux
whoops whatever now like that y'all know
[Music]
this episode is solo I'm working hard
dreaming big like I'm Coco y'all hear
the phones and you didn't know
Oh rarity the house with some quick
flows
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
wit is so low
so they bassoon he said hey Jamie
[Music]
yes son
solo episode solo episode alert what's
up y'all welcome back to riffing with
Griffin this is another special solo
episode so make sure you subscribe share
like you know help me grow the show I
feel like I'm that little show that
nobody knows about so I need your help
but if you want to become a member
please do that too you could become a
youtube member you know with
subscription member I'm still working on
what I'm gonna do for that you could be
a patreon member to help me grow the
show help me pay an intern to come in
here and like you know make it even
bigger and better for y'all but welcome
back like I say to riff from a Griffin
I'm your host Eric Griffin and excuse me
I'm still coughing scray see you know
something I got an air purifier and like
everything's been better like that
the woo-woos are back somewhat you know
what I mean that's why I didn't do my
Christmas album really disappointed
about that I might do a Valentine's
album but I don't know let me not even
like make promises that I can't keep but
here we are I'm doing another look again
here we are doing a solo episode having
some fun on the internet you know doing
a green screen stuff on on Instagram and
you know I'm just trying to like final
different ways to be fun and funny and
put out new content you know because
that's just what you know just really is
all about it's just me having fun and
sharing my fun with you guys but
unfortunately though before I even
decided to do this do a solo episode
there was some sad news in the world
especially if you're if you're a la
person if you're a basketball fan just
and actually just just regular human
being you know the tragic sad passing a
basketball player Kobe Bryant at age 41
with his daughter on a helicopter crash
and by the way seven other people too
and and their families you know it's
just sad that when if you die with
somebody super famous knowing you're
just kind of an afterthought but let's
not you know be rude to those people and
so you know I pay homage to those people
too and it's just a sad sad situation
you know it's you know and then you know
I'm doing this but I don't want to come
across like you know it's like I'm cloud
chasing or whatever
like that that that kind of feeling cuz
I can't stand when like death sucks all
around it just sucks because the way it
affects everybody is in such a weird
morbid way but I also can't stand when
people die and then the people that are
left people that don't even know the
person or or even if they know the
person a little bit they act like oh my
god phone call you know I'm not going to
answer that you know what's weird about
this I've been getting these weird like
your your tax I bet you this is what
this is you know what I'm gonna answer
this so you can hear this is to notify
you that due to a certain suspicious
activities related to your social
security number we have been forced to
suspend your social security number with
immediate effect due to this all your
social benefits will be canceled until
from in clearance really in case you
feel I mean it's ridiculous that I keep
getting that phone call I mean I keep
getting that phone call and it's like a
weird coming from a weird eight one
eight number and I have to I have to
keep blocking this number so look out
for that guys I know we in the middle of
talk about something serious but you
know you guys should look out for this
like these weird eight one eight numbers
or 800 numbers or not eight one eight
800 numbers they're actually this fake
you know the this irx IRS or you know
the the what do you call it the Social
Security is gonna suspend your social
security number - it's fake the
government never calls you like that
there's hundreds of millions of people
the United States you think they're
calling people individually it's all
fake but that you know that was like
that's what that is it's so annoying but
anyways if you're getting that you know
that's why I played that right now but
anyways back to Kobe Bryant like I say
people die and then everybody like
people love to they I don't know what it
is but people love to like feel like
they need you know like you know like it
affects them more than it really does or
something or they are they love to eat
you know the attention that the
get from people you know because someone
died you know like how it affects them
you know I remember this comic died a
few years back and I was just annoyed
with all the like everybody acting like
first of all everybody acting like this
guy was Richard Pryor all of a sudden
and you know just like eight benefit
shows I was like what's going on here
and then like people going to talk at
the wake and all this guy I'm like do
you really know this guy like like I
didn't want I thought it would be
disrespectful for me to speak on it at
all cuz I didn't really know him that
well you know I mean it's just one of
those things you know it's like it's
sometimes it's like just a certain point
where it becomes disrespectful in my
opinion you know it's like it's a
certain point where you're mourning
someone and you're saying nice things
and you're in you're being respectful
and then when does it become about you
and it's not about you you know so that
happens a lot and then I think it's
gonna start happening with this kobe
bryant thing you know it's like yo
they're saying about you you know but
you know it is what it is he was such a
like a powerful figure and everybody in
the Los Angeles life if you're super
into basketball just knowing about him
and just like his down up up bad times
you know down times I mean he really was
a popular figure I mean think about it
he went through that stuff in Denver
came through all that and then won an
Oscar you know and in a time where like
you know you know that the me ii was
just starting to take take effect and it
was like and he still is
that's how loved he is you know but
anyways and there's a lot of negativity
like you know this comics that I know
that are putting out a lot of negative
[ __ ] about Kobe Bryant I just I feel
like it's just rude to me cuz even if
even if you don't like him even if you
thought he got away with something eight
other people died including his daughter
like there's a time and place for
everything whatever message you're
trying to give and I just don't think
this is the time for that like on the
day of the guy's death you know and at
the same time too though it's like yo
guys like people there's always jokes
I remember when NASA I remember when the
astronauts when I was a kid and you know
that the Space Shuttle blew up and then
the media jokes were like NASA it's it
need another seven astron
that's what that was one of the first
you know horrific jokes that came out
but you know some people have a morbid
sense of humor you know uh like know the
difference between a joke and somebody
just specifically putting out a lot of
hate so there is a lot of hate out there
but I never was a super fan of Kobe
Bryant like I wasn't a fan not that I
didn't think he was great I was a hater
like he was just one of those guys that
is so fun to hate you know every time he
did something it was just like every
accomplishment you you know when you're
a hater you find a way to take it away I
will get Pau Gasol oh yes Shaquille
O'Neal the 81-point game you're like
well you know you had one assist you
know it's like you just there's always
there's always something to talk about
with him and that's what I think I'll
remember the most you know like even
with my group of guys that I play
fantasy football with we you know we
always get into heated debates about
who's the best ever who's the best ever
Kobe Jordan magic LeBron now you know we
always just fight about then there's
guys in my group didn't thing like
Kobe's the end-all be-all so it's fun to
argue with Kobe fans you know but this
is a sad day like when he retired I
didn't want to see him go out like that
like three years of like just
injury-prone you know he just was a
shell of himself at that point I kind of
wanted to see him go out fighting for a
championship you know like on the court
maybe I wanted to see him lose to
someone I mean the sad thing is what we
never got was that LeBron Kobe
championship that's what we really
wanted we really wanted to add LeBron
Kobe thing but I just did that never
happened you know
LeBron didn't live up to the bill on
that one right there they had those
stupid puppet commercials I mean it
would have just been epic in the same
way that I'm sure State Farm wanted
Aaron Rodgers to make it to the Super
Bowl cuz then it would have been like
all managing all the commercials and
stuff they would have done for that
sometimes you know it just doesn't work
out the way people wanted it to and I
feel like that uh that championship with
we wanted to see LeBron versus Kobe
never happened but you know listen the
guy had an illustrious career and he was
starting a really great post career you
know you know like I say it in a movie
business and then coaching his girls and
you know having that basketball the
Mamba basketball academy or whatever it
is I'm not sure exactly if it's just for
basketball but I think it's just working
out in general so he was like heading in
his life so why would a tragic loss or
and it's so jarring for us because we
feel like someone like that aw someone
like that they're not gonna they're
gonna die the right way whatever that
means not something like this you know
it's just it's a tragedy and my best
wishes go - my condolences to his family
and all the families that were on that
helicopter cuz you know [ __ ] I mean I
just it's just a tragic thing to even
think about that you're in this
helicopter with your 13 year old
daughter and you're just like what do
you do you know what I mean like what do
you do it's like those closing moments
those last moments must have been just
terrible so let's hope if there is an
afterlife that you know everybody is at
peace you know so but anyways that's
what I wanted to say about that a lot of
stuff out there too to talk about you
know this M&M this new M&M album like I
feel like I'm an old head so when I look
at rap and hip-hop and I I think of it
in old terms you know I like Tupac and
Biggie and you know Eric being Rakim
EPMD I like these old guys you know it's
hard to realize I think I think the
thing that sup would rap is like this is
this is now rappers are old you know so
this is we've lived through this like
it's one thing like to see like I just
saw the Grammys this past weekend and
like Aerosmith was out there with Run
DMC and these [ __ ] look old as
hell like they were jumping around for a
second and they have the performance
they were just stand-in there like okay
this is about is all we gonna move now
cuz they're old but like Aerosmith can
still go on concert they can still tour
they can still do what they do like rock
and other genres they're not youth based
they're not like they start young but
they are appreciated like look at the
Grateful Dead like the Grateful Dead was
touring for a year they where they were
like a you know a juggernaut they were
just torn for forever so Aerosmith they
still could go on tour
Bon Jovi goes on tour you know all these
old metal and rock groups they're still
out there doing it Paul McCartney still
out there doing it you know he's doctor
you know Smokey Robinson is still doing
it but when it comes to rap when it
comes to hip hop for some reason there's
some ageism involved in it you know and
I don't know if that's gonna go away I
think it's gonna take another 20 years
before we can still appreciate the whole
genre but right now when a rapper gets
old it's like okay get him out of here
even like jay-z like even though jay-z
is like he's 40-something so it's
getting to the point where people like I
is cool man but it's time for you to get
out of rap or he just he don't have the
same allure and I think that's what's
going on with Eminem right now you know
people going at this dude all the time
and [ __ ] like Machine Gun Kelly and Nick
Nick Cannon I don't know what the [ __ ]
Nick can like I want to come out with a
diss track now if anybody could just do
a diss track like you know and I'm
addressed that but let me just say I
just let me finish my point about rap
how this rappers are now old like some
of the old dignitaries are like LL Cool
J right people don't even know l oqj was
a rapper they think he's just an actor
on CSI one of those CSIC city's City
show you know CSI LA or whatever one
he's on he's now just an actor ice-t
another guy dignitary of hip-hop
he's been on he's but he's actually been
an actor I think longer than he's been
he was a rapper so you know you know
that's how people know these people you
know and even like jay-z is known to be
like now he's a mogul he's like this you
know he's married to Beyonce to the
young people you know so it's
interesting to see rappers get old and
what they can do it themselves cuz in
all these because then the sound changes
too which is kind of weird you know the
sound like I saw this mumble rapping and
like this like all the all the basically
all the songs sound the same you know
it's weird but even though I look back
and I think about anything that came out
of the wu-tang clan it all sounded that
same thing you know DJ premier his beats
they all sounded you know everybody on
those songs like Eric being rock and
they got like five of their songs get to
say
type of beat so this not a new thing but
and it's weird house not being
appreciated by the next generation they
look back on it as like aunt whatever
because even you know cuz watching the
Grammys is like first of all watching
the Grammys is just terrible listen I'm
getting off topic again we go get back
to Eminem but let me just say real quick
the Grammys it's like it's hard to watch
the Grammys unless you're watching it
with people that are from your own age
group because I think don't number one
question watching the Grammys with
everybody is who's that
who who's that what are they doing there
it's just it's so weird who they select
to perform and why and I don't know it's
just it's just a weird you know the
Grammys are a weird hodgepodge of
different styles and genres I mean I
prefer like when you watch like the
Country Music Awards like if you watch
the Country Music Awards that's like you
know what you're gonna get it's this is
all country music you're not gonna have
to worry about you know some classical
coming in or you're some rap or like
hip-hop or anything like that it's just
like okay this is country music so let
me just appreciate this I kind of like
that as opposed to when you look at the
Grammys there's just so much this of all
genres ages you know then they're there
remembering people from old and and it's
just it's a really weird thing with your
Grammys but anyways getting back to
Eminem I just okay so like I said I'm an
old head is he an old rapper I don't
know I can't is he you know it's hard to
I don't know and I think unfortunately
he's a victim of being white I if Eminem
wasn't white would he be great I think
part of his greatness is the fact that
he was white and he had this limitation
of what he could talk about as a rapper
like he never says the n-word imagine if
he said like oh my god it would just be
crazy right so he never says that so
then he can't is it cultural
appropriation you know he's from Detroit
he's from 8 mile you know he grew up
poor trailer trailer trash you know what
I mean like that's equivalent to
Auto rappers talk about coming up in the
ghetto and having to sell drugs and
other their own stories so we had a
parallel story so then but then again he
was limited to how he could talk about
it and what he could talk about so I
think that made him great like it's a
shame that there's all this talk about
like well he's white and so because he's
white that's why people think he's the
greatest of all time the people that are
saying non black but like damn just
who's prolific man he's still going like
how long has he been in the game and you
know just race aside you know it's not
always not always great on his albums
but he's consistent his rap style his
lyrics the beats you know it's
ever-changing he evolves with the time
and and so you have to like pick and
choose like okay what do I like about
this what do I not like about this but
there's so much to analyze there's so
much to enjoy and I just think that it's
a shame maybe maybe in 20 more years
we're gonna look back and be like look
how great this guy was but that being
said just a new album I don't know if
I'm saying this because I'm an old head
or am I saying this because what I'm
saying is true I think this album is
great it's one of his best albums ever
he got a couple of songs where I think
like the studio was like whoever the the
the record company was like yo can we
put off some bangers give me some hits
cuz he's somethin he talked about in the
past I was like always having to come up
with that on Slim Shady type song so he
always had one of those you know guess
who's back back ugh and he always came
up with a song like that and it was like
that was like okay here's the radio jam
but then you gotta listen to the album
to hear all the deep cuts here all the
things that really like you know you
know and then he came out with that
album that was just like you know a
retaliation album to everybody talking
smack about him then he comes out with
another album I mean the guy just keeps
putting out albums and songs and like
it's it's so great you know but I really
enjoyed this album not gonna play any
songs from it but I'm just telling you
you know if you you should really take a
listen to it like actually pull up the
UM let me let me just put up must pull
up my Spotify right now just like in
[Music]
just go over some of the stuff some some
of the songs in the album that I that I
did I really liked you know so this new
album is called music to be murdered by
and I'm telling you dude all these songs
are dope you know [ __ ] you gonna learn
is Godzilla's dope I love God you know
you just I mean all these are great man
darkness is great oh man it's just I
just think that there is so much
prolific work on this album that but I
don't know if young people like it or do
young people not like it because he's
old like just rap need to be just young
that's the question
let me know what you think in the
comments you know is rap a young man's
game is it strictly a young man's game
is it strictly whatever is popular and
hip at the time is that the only people
that can rap do all people have because
it seems as if like in the rap world
here's a sound and everybody's doing it
you know and this is the only you know
just the only sound you can have but you
know and then like I said earlier Nick
Cannon is going after him and I just I
don't get it maybe they had something
some thing about Mariah Carey but you
left her like what you know I mean she
should be coming at him I don't know so
that Nick Cannon had this song it's I
don't like it and then everything comes
back in just like here's the problem
here's a situation Eminem is in do you
respond because responding to Nick
Cannon gives the cannon like a career as
a rapper like you know what I mean like
it makes people think like oh this is a
real beef going on so you can take it
kind of gives him clout but then you
don't say anything and then like it's
like what did Clinton win it's just
because he's famous enough that hey
maybe you you know people know enough
about cuz I'm sure there's plenty of
people that are like rap like like
there's all these things about all these
people in the rap world who were talking
[ __ ] about Eminem who he's going after I
don't know who the [ __ ] these people are
I don't care I'm not that into the world
Ron no like some some b-side artist or
buddy who's like you know he's he's had
a few albums and all of a sudden you
know you know he talks about Eminem and
now people know about him I don't know
some of those guys but I just know I do
know who Nick Cannon is cuz he's sort of
in the comedy world so I could see why
it would be a thing but part of me feels
like Eminem shouldn't responded at all
and then he can't name when he did
respond it's like that same usual like
that guy goes for the jugular that's
what you have to respect them and them
for like he don't mess around he's going
that your mama you know he's going for
the throat man music to be murdered by
so I don't know you got a check it out I
do I do highly recommend you check out
that [ __ ] huh okay what else happened in
the world that I wanted to talk about
there was this I'm not sure what I don't
know if it was the Hollywood Reporter or
I'm sure if it was like variety whatever
but there was like something about
something about the Oscar nominations
you know and it was like once again
talking about oh it's all white it's all
male it's all this it's all that and my
thing is like that takes away from you
know to me it takes away from what the
Oscars are in the first place you know
say if we have to always worry about
what am I trying to say at what point is
it about the merit of the work versus
the optics of who's being nominated and
who decides that because the court of
public opinion is this they want it to
be casted you know let's cast it let's
uh let's make it where we have a certain
number of women certain um minorities
and so when people watch it they can
feel good about themselves that they you
know that they that their virtue is
intact they've hurt you signal to
themselves into like being at home being
like yes now this is the kind of award
show I want to see where everyone is
included do you want that or do you want
like these were the best movies and this
year they just happen to be all white or
it happened to be all white males are
the stars of the best movies what do you
suppose
- do you know I don't know cuz to me it
takes away from it with all this talk or
the talk talk talk talk talk talk talk
it just just makes you go okay so when
they do actually nominate something you
it takes away from them because you go
well I guess they nominated that because
everybody was talking [ __ ] so I guess we
got to put this movie up and then maybe
the movie really is good like moonlight
moonlight was a great movie but I feel
like that was right when Oscars so white
and all that stuff was going on then the
black gay movie wins and then what what
do you say you guys finally or you go
huh is that because it so I thought it
took away from it I thought the movement
took away from it you know and I know
I've talked about this before um yeah
you know what's what's what's important
man is it what's important what do you
guys think is important is it like like
I say merit you know so my thing look it
starts in to me it starts in the
development phase you know if we want to
change if we want more women more
minorities more people in show business
it has to start in the development phase
it can't be like later not in casting
not that's not where it has to change
because you know look if you're like
it's so easy if you're making a movie
and it's pre-1970 either it's gonna be
racism involved if it's some biopic
about anybody or you know or the cast is
gonna be mostly white you know that you
go back even further if it's gonna be
like anything about you know you know
the westerns history of anything in
Europe you know it's always white
everything is white white white why
because it was mostly white people my
people are still the majority so you
know to have this you know idea that we
have to we have some responsibility to
make everything look like everyone's
included well then let's start at the
point where where the writers are people
who are writing for the people that they
understand writing you know who the
directors you know the whole development
phase has to be changed there but
until that happens this is what we have
here's where we are you know you have a
movie like the Joker what are you
supposed to act like the Joker wasn't
great
what are we supposed to act like you
know movies like that like do you do a
movie like the Irishman
so anything has to do with the mob or
anything like that any Scorsese movie
there's gonna be zero black people in it
you know what I mean or it's gonna be
very few very limited cuz that's what he
likes it
are those movies not great should they
not be nominated you know it's like it's
like every year this is the thing you
know there are a lot of movies out there
but they you have to keep putting those
movies out so we could change our
perspective you know because it's not
that like I'm just speaking for me as a
man I don't I don't mind watching
anything and actually as a minority let
me make this point as a minority when I
was coming up we had to watch whatever
was on TV yes I loved Martin the show
Martin was great it was funny but I also
thought friends was funny and Seinfeld
was funny and Three's Company was funny
and and all the numerous all-white
programs are on TV because if I decided
to myself well I'm not gonna watch
anything unless I got black people on it
I'm not gonna watch anything unless it's
got females if you act like that you
ain't gonna be able to watch [ __ ] so for
me I just was like okay I watch anything
and I appreciated all the funniness that
I saw you don't I mean I remember having
a conversation with a white friend of
mine a long time ago and he was like he
didn't like Martin because he was like I
just don't get it whatever you know so
he just didn't watch it you know I mean
as a minority I didn't have that luxury
because if I only like I say if I only
watched a more certain type of thing
there wasn't a lot of options so the
more options you have I think more
people would be like oh I like that I
like that I like that I like that you
know like when The Cosby Show came out
it was more you know it was more like
here's a lawyer and a doctor and a
family man and Ike well you know listen
we know how everything turned out but
I'm just talking about the fictional
version of the that show everybody loved
that show because it would transcended
color and race and all that it was about
you know here's some upper-class
economics and then you know so as people
at home like oh I can relate to this you
know you know what I mean so
that's what you need you know like I
think give an example of a show I really
[ __ ] love good girls I don't know
what Network gets on because I watch it
on Netflix but I think it's on like a
ray I think it's on a BCC but one of
those Neph Fox I don't know what network
it's on because I only watch it on
Netflix I just recently started watching
it and I zipped through the whole two
seasons that show is great and it's just
about that the stars are these three
women and they rob a convenient they
were market and it's just all the things
that go on after that and you just get
involved in their lives and they're
great actresses in this great story and
the more you do more great stuff you
make like that anybody watch it and be
like oh this is great there's nobody out
here that I know of not me going ain't
watching nothing if it's all female I
mean you know that's ridiculous you know
and by the way going back to Kobe Bryant
I think I think one of the things that
one of the last things he said publicly
was he said there are some women that
can play in the NBA and now we'll never
know if he was just saying that because
he has daughters and he coaches his
daughter and he wants his daughter to
achieve that whatever she can if you
just said it because it's the right it's
you know it's one of those things you
say even if you mean it or not you know
it's like you know so that's out there
that statements out there and that's the
one of the things that you know what he
tried to do for the WNBA and for women
to push them forward you know he made up
for his infidelity you know I think
that's what his mission was to be a
better man better family man this
happens to people you make mistakes you
know when you go on and yeah I don't
know what happened in Denver with Kobe
Bryant know if he did it or not he
wasn't convicted you know who knows the
circumstances that those kinds of things
cuz I think all this has been in those
situations but the main thing the first
thing he did wrong was he was cheating
on his life you know I mean he had to
call in other women he cheated on his
wife with to testify that he wasn't a
violent in bed violent person so you
know how messed up is that right so he
tried I think he tried to make up for
that thing with that statement so here
we are so that's you know that's gonna
be one more thing to in
to normalize what we see on TV and what
we see in sports is that this should
just be a thing like I'm tired of always
having to point out you know people's
race gender and sexual orientation like
we always have to worry about that the
answer should be so [ __ ] what who
cares but and so we have to put out more
product the development stage more shows
like good girl you know it was this one
book what is it called
bookworm or book something anyway it's
this story about these two so mu it was
a movie about these two girls I wish I
can I want to get the right name you
guys don't tell me in the comments and
everybody don't know what I'm talking
about but I don't know if it was called
bookworm or you know book smart book
smart okay so this is a story two girls
are the heroes in the movie but this is
what I thought was weird about it all
right so the lead is one of the leads is
a heavyset girl she's a fat girl alright
and the other girl the skinnier one the
more the girl that would be more like oh
she's deleting the lead girl in a movie
they made her lesbian okay so I'm
looking at this movie and I'm like who's
this for it's certainly not for guys 18
to 35 because you know when you go to a
movie you wanna you want to see who am I
in this movie I want to be the hero I
want to be Thor when you watch it or
you're like you see the the female
character and you're like oh I could
picture myself with her in this movie
you might not necessarily have done that
because the girl that was like the you
know more you know aesthetically
whatever Hollywood pretty girl she's
lesbian and the other girl if you're not
into bad girls you not gonna like her
either so there was nothing like there
was no there might not have been a lot
of sexual appeal if you're watching you
know the as a dude I'm saying and then
the stories were you know it's all
women's stuff but I watched it and I
enjoyed the movie and I was like oh man
there needs to be more movies like this
so little girls at home are watching in
there and they see themselves they see
them so they're like oh I'm just like
this girl or I'm just like that girl I'm
just like these other characters in the
movie and then
some of the guys in the movie are you
watching us a guy you'd be like oh you
know what I have been the nerd friend or
I have been this guy that I you know was
was insecure about whatever you know you
know I mean it's just so there's just
one movie where by surface you go oh
here's a chick flick I want a chick
movie for women but this is just that
one so you could just avoid it because
there's 15 other superhero movies as a
guy you could be like well I'm gonna
ignore that one let me go to see these
other ones and I did don't even watch
because I was on a plane you know and I
said I'll be check this out but I wasn't
gonna buy a ticket for it but if you put
out more movies like that you put out
more movies that are starring women but
they have topics that are like universal
topics that we can all relate to
family friends overcoming adversity of
you know coming-of-age stories you put
out more stories that have met women
black people Latino just put out just
stories then people will start to watch
them and realize oh we're pretty much
all the same but if all you offer if all
you offer is all white mostly white
majority white well then the rest of us
we gotta go okay well this is all
they're offering so but hey I enjoyed it
I still like Avengers even though
there's only one black character like I
say I watched friends I watched Seinfeld
loved these shows they're classic love
some lot of the movies that are
nominated loved a joker joker was mostly
white so you know i mean like what are
we supposed to do
I mean we're watching so that's why it
has to be in the development stage of
what's happening you know you got to put
and you got put out more product so
people understand so people can
appreciate it and so we have to bombard
the public with like you know more than
just moonlight more than just like okay
people are talking so let's uh hey we
need more female directors right now
because this is a you know this is the
call we've been [ __ ] up for so long
so now let's try to like get it all back
in one year then the turnaround the next
year and look at all the shows on TV
look at all the shelves on TV once again
they're mostly white we're just it's as
if nothing happened in the last two
years
you wait another year and it's gonna be
like once again it's gonna be like what
it is look it because look what they're
complaining about already they're
complaining that like all nine best
picture movies are mostly all starring
men about man for men you know so what
happened what was the movement all about
this is all the stuff that was in
development you know so again I'm not
I'm not I'm not trying to come off like
I'm some victim or like you know I'm
like oh you know fight the power nah no
I'm not saying none of that stuff I'm
really talking about if we start in the
development stage and just start
developing more projects that and just
add people that look like all kinds of
different people but once you make a
good product
I think everyone including white people
are gonna look at this and be like hey
you know what that was pretty good but
until it happens we're just gonna be
stuck with when no award shows come
around these are the movies that are
being nominated because those are the
best movies being made okay that's why
all right
I hope I made sense if I didn't make
sense you can always you know write in
the comments like you guys always do to
tell me that I don't make sense but yeah
man just a little bonus 30 minute
episode I wanted to put out midweek
because I want to start doing this more
and I'm gonna release some early for my
patreon and my YouTube members so I want
you to come out and be a YouTube and
patreon member so come on there's the
link right there pal patreon come join
me guys help me grow this damn show help
me so I don't even have to like do
anything else but this bring you great
wonderful content thought-provoking some
of you are mad at me good let's talk
about it you know if you want to go into
the comments you want to say stuff don't
be you don't got to be rude yeah I mean
somebody some of you say things it's
like I read this stuff and I go god damn
why is this person what is the point of
calling me a fat [ __ ] you know I mean if
you have some point if you're even if
you're like even if you're some white
guy out there right now that is furious
about people always talking about women
and minorities and you want
you want to make your point make your
point I'll hear you and then we'll see
what happens
you know let's have a discussion a
dialogue I think that's what we're
missing right now is people like it
don't be a coward don't be a coward you
know me my [ __ ] says Eric Griffin I got
an email you can if you want to come see
me live you know where I'm gonna be but
some of you bitch-ass Punk's out there
with your no picture as your profile you
know a weird like you know Chuck a
teacher Chuck from you know Chucky Chuck
Cincinnati or you don't even put even
where you're from you just have some
weird username put your [ __ ] name on
it you want to say something messed up
put your name on hi my name is this this
I live in this city and this is what I
do for a living
put that out there and this is what I
look like put your [ __ ] out there bro
put it out there let's say then let's
see what what how you how you feel about
when people come at you but if you have
something respectful and
thought-provoking to say I'm all about
it let's do that okay but anyways once
again this is a quickie but you want to
put some thoughts out there best wishes
to the you know and condolences to the
Kobe Bryant family and all the families
on that helicopter and and and how it
affected everybody in the sports world
and beyond it's a really shocking one to
see someone such a high regarded public
figure has done so much you know in his
professional life that we recognize and
have enjoyed to see him gone at the
young age of 41 [ __ ] I'm older than Kobe
Bryant it's like damn it
it really makes you like you want you
need to go out and I think about what
you're doing in your own life and make
sure you know you're taking care of
business out there
Eminem album Eminem album I think is
great so make sure you listen to that
you know and let me know what you think
in the comments do you think I'm just
old and you like I don't get just music
he's too old to be rapping still let me
know what you think about that
discussion I was having with myself and
of course also about the Oscars and
Hollywood and the development stage of
making new products so we can get past
this whole idea of casting the oscar
awards and all the awards to make sure
that it's all inclusive as opposed to
let's make sure we're
we're giving people the awards that they
deserve so let me know what you think
about that and let me know if you want
me to keep doing these like little
quickie episodes this is a quick bonus
episode of the week this week's episode
was Michael Rosenbaum
he was Lex Luthor on Smallville he's
been on a bunch of stuff he's a great
dude so that episodes out make sure you
take a look at that but anyway this has
been Erik Griffin let a little quick
bonus episode bonus riffin bonus solo
riffing I don't even know what to call
it you let's come up with a name for
that too but we solo riffing y'all and
thank you for listening as always
subscribe share like and I appreciate
y'all take care
[Music]